la guerre en ukraine est entré
aujourd'hui dans sa septième semaine et
l'est du pays désormais cible
prioritaire de la russie s'attend à une
nouvelle offensive russe et continuent
d'évacuer sa population civile hier 1200
personnes ont pu quitter la région de
loin ce que selon son gouverneur mais
dans des conditions très difficiles en
l'absence de tous lcf cessez le feu on
va retrouver un pour en parler le
correspondant de rfi en ukraine stéphane
sion bonjour stéphane comment se
déroulent ces évacuations de civils dans
l'est du pays
alors vous savez les autorités
ukrainiennes appelle ces manoeuvres
d'évacuation l'opération de la dernière
chance alors que l'état-major à kiev
estime que les forces russes sont en
train de se regrouper et pourrait lancer
une offensive majeure dans l'est de
l'ukraine dans un horizon d'environ
trois à quatre jours ce qui est certain
c'est que pour les ukrainiens la
situation est beaucoup plus précaire
dans le donbass qu'ailleurs en ukraine
alors l'objectif des autorités est
d'éviter le maximum de personnes civiles
de pertes civiles mais également de
personnes qui seraient enfermés au
milieu des combats mais aussi des drames
humains comme celui qui s'est déroulé à
marioupol ce que l'on sait pour cette
journée de jeudi c'est que les autorités
ukrainiennes et russes se sont mis
d'accord pour dix couloirs humanitaires
principalement dans les régions de
lougansk au nord du donbass et de
marioupol au sud du donbass seulement
malgré les efforts du gouvernement
ukrainien a pour évacuer ces personnes
civiles il y a encore des difficultés
matérielles les trains ne fonctionne pas
bien parce que les voies ferrées ont été
bombardés par les par les forces russes
rien que pour la journée de mercredi ce
sont 5000 personnes qui sont sorties du
dombass les trois quarts dans la région
de marioupol mais c'est encore peu par
rapport aux besoins humains alors que
des villes comme c'est vers audonienne
sq le slavia soukra matt horth pourrait
être prise dans l'étau des combats dans
quelques jours à noter que le président
volodymyr zelensky signale que les
autorités russes font ce qu'elles
peuvent pour éviter les évacuations de
marioupol selon le président ukrainien
le kremlin souhaiterait à éviter au
maximum des témoignages sur la situation
humanitaire dramatique dans la ville
assiégée c'est fade vous vous êtes à
kiev en ce moment même où l'étau
militaires semblent s'être desserrer ces
derniers jours est ce que l'on est en
train de revenir à une situation normale
entre guillemets bien sûr dans la
capitale ukrainienne
pas encore je dirais alors on va dire
que la situation s'est améliorée par
rapport à celle qui prévalait il ya
environ un mois cela fait désormais
plusieurs jo qu'il n'y a pas eu de
bombardement sur les périphéries de la
ville est désormais la crainte d'un
assaut massif semble écartée
résultat le centre-ville de pierre
revient petit à petit à la vie des
commerces des cafés des services
commencent à réouvrir j'ai aussi noté
depuis hier une augmentation du trafic
automobile ce qui veut dire que de
nombreux habitants sont en train de
revenir dans la ville je suis même resté
coincé dans le premier embouteillage
depuis cette semaine ce qui est un signe
qui ne trompe pas néanmoins la
municipalité de kiev met en garde contre
cet afflux et conseils ok vient de
différer leur retour d'au moins une
semaine afin d'observer la situation en
effet ce midi il ya des sirènes qui ont
encore retenti dans le centre ville de
kiev pour la mairie le risque de
bombardements par des missiles
balistiques n'est toujours pas écartée
la capitale est donc bien entendu
largement sous administration militaire
est désormais la grande bataille qui
avec la grande bataille qui s'annonce
dans le donbass la ville de kiev
pourrait passer de la situation d'une
ville de front d'une ville assiégée à
une ville d'arrière front concentrer sur
le soutien à l'effort de guerre merci
beaucoup stéphane suivant en direct de
kiev